en el primer vídeo de transporte pasivo
hablamos del transporte más pasivo de
los pasivos que existe hablamos de la
difusión simple recuerdas y hablamos de
por qué las moléculas pequeñas sin carga
es decir no polares pueden pasar
fácilmente de un lado a otro por ejemplo
moléculas como el dióxido de carbono o
el oxígeno molecular pueden atravesar
con gran facilidad la membrana celular
estas moléculas son lo suficientemente
pequeñas para pasar por los pequeños
huecos de aquí que tenemos por aquí y
debido a que no tienen carga o polaridad
pasarán casi desapercibidas también
hablamos de que hay moléculas
intermedias como el agua que son lo
suficientemente pequeñas para pasar por
los huecos que tenemos aquí pero tienen
un poco de polaridad una cierta
polaridad por lo tanto no pueden pasar
tan fácilmente pero al final podrán
filtrarse después hablamos de aquellas
moléculas que no pueden pasar fácilmente
y estas son las partículas cargadas como
pusimos de ejemplo teníamos iones
odio o iones de potasio y estos aunque
son bastante pequeños van a interactuar
mucho con las cabezas de los fosfatos
que tenemos aquí justo por aquí lo tenía
representado y entonces al ser moléculas
cargadas será muy difícil que atraviesen
la membrana pero de lo que quiero hablar
en este vídeo todavía es sobre
transporte pasivo y recuerda el
transporte pasivo es aquel movimiento a
favor del gradiente de concentración
pero ahora hablaremos de formas en las
que el transporte pasivo se facilita
para este tipo de moléculas estas que
tienen carga lo que vamos a hacer es que
su transporte pasivo se ha facilitado
entonces de lo que hablaremos en este
vídeo es acerca de la difusión
facilitada déjame escribirlo aquí voy a
hablar de la d
fu
sión facilitada
sí
en el vídeo pasado hablamos sobre
difusión ahora vamos a hablar sobre cómo
se facilita entonces imagínate que tú
quieres
diseñar algo que permita que este tipo
de moléculas cambiase las moléculas de
agua o los iones que tenemos aquí se
puedan mover más fácil a favor de su
cliente de concentración qué harías
a lo mejor dirías bueno si no tuviera
que lidiar con todo esto que tengo aquí
con todas las cabezas hidrofílicas y
después con las colas hidrofóbicas sería
mucho más fácil moverme a favor del
gradiente de concentración y justo lo
que surgió en la naturaleza es algo para
evitar todos estos obstáculos
esencialmente lo que tenemos son túneles
que atraviesen la membrana entonces la
forma de facilitar la difusión es con
canales formados por proteínas como este
que tenemos aquí y los primeros que
vamos a ver que facilitan el transporte
pasivo son los canales proteicos déjame
escribirlos aquí vamos a hablar
de los canales proteicos
lees
proteicos
y un ejemplo de canal proteico puede ser
este de aquí y este de aquí puede ser un
canal proteico es decir un túnel donde
puedan pasar con mayor facilidad a lo
mejor este es un canal para transportar
agua ya este tipo de canales se les
llama acuaporinas a los que transportan
agua se les conoce con el nombre de a
one
tú
y las acuaporinas que esencialmente son
canales proteicos donde pasa el agua y
como puedes ver tienen un hoyo en la
parte superior justo por aquí y ahora
digamos que tenemos más moléculas de
agua afuera que adentro déjame poner
muchas más moléculas de agua afuera que
adentro y queremos que el agua se mueva
a favor de su gradiente de concentración
o no sea tal vez a lo mejor tengas mayor
concentración de soluto aquí en el
interior de la célula entonces sucederá
osmosis y por lo tanto será más probable
que las moléculas se muevan de afuera
hacia adentro que de adentro hacia
afuera así observa que las moléculas van
a pasar por aquí van a pasar por aquí
así ya no tendrán que interactuar con la
membrana y será mucho más fácil cruzar
de afuera hacia adentro solo atravesarán
esta parte gracias ala aquaporina y
llegar al interior de las
ahora también tenemos canales proteicos
para los iones por ejemplo este de aquí
puede ser uno de estos canales se me
ocurre que es un canal proteico para
iones de sodio entonces imagínate que
por aquí tenemos algunos iones de sodio
por aquí están cargados y por lo tanto
tendrían muchos problemas para pasar a
través de la membrana pero este canal al
ser un canal específico para este tipo
de iones bueno les va a permitir pasar
fácilmente por aquí y así puedan
atravesar la membrana sin dificultad van
a salir por acá y como veremos cuando
estudias cosas como las neuronas veremos
como estos canales proteicos
especialmente para guiones son muy
importantes para la amplificación de las
señales eléctricas o más bien podría
decir de las señales electroquímicas
estos canales también pueden tener un
tipo de compuerta que se puede abrir o
cerrar dependiendo de las condiciones
que existan afuera o adentro de la
célula entonces los canales pueden estar
siempre abiertos
pueden abrirse y cerrarse de acuerdo a
las condiciones ambientales esto está
genial y justo esto es lo que sucede las
células nerviosas como veremos en
futuros vídeos bueno otro tipo de
difusión facilitada sucede gracias a
unas proteínas que se llaman lo voy a
poner así proteínas acarreadores
proteínas acarreadores proteínas
acarreador as y ya está voy a hablar
acerca de estas proteínas pero todavía
los investigadores siguen estudiando
cómo trabajan exactamente aunque todavía
no se sabe bien la idea general es la
siguiente voy a dibujar aquí en una
membrana y déjame ponerlo así voy a
poner aquí mis cabezas hidrofílicas aquí
tengo tres cabezas hidrofílicas voy a
poner aquí también otras tres otras 3
recuerda que es una bicapa fosfolípido
así que lo estoy poniendo aquí tengo mis
cabezas hidrofílicas y ahora voy a
dibujar sus colas hidrofóbicas así que
déjame ponerlas
3 y bueno también por cada una
ya se acabó una
23 y ahora por aquí voy a poner esta
proteína acarreador a se va a ver más o
menos así algo más o menos así por aquí
algo así y bueno también del otro lado
se va a ver algo más o menos así
recuerda que no es un dibujo exacto pero
más o menos así se ven estas proteínas a
cargadoras y ahora lo que queremos es
que las cosas se muevan a favor de su
creciente de concentración así que
imagínate que por aquí tengo una cierta
particular y digamos que hay una mayor
concentración de la particular arriba
que abajo así que déjame poner varios
puntitos por aquí y bueno estas
partículas entran a un compartimiento a
este compartimento que voy a dibujar
justo por aquí y se unen a la proteína y
esto causa que la proteína cargadora
cambie de forma déjame ver si puedo
hacer girar esta proteína que tengo aquí
para que veas cómo cambia de forma
esencialmente lo que va a hacer es girar
voy a atrapar a esta proteína que tengo
aquí y ahora quiero que ver lo siguiente
déjame ver si la puedo traer por aquí
justo eso es lo que quiero pero ahora va
a cambiar completamente o va a girar
completamente su lado y se va a ver más
o menos así se abrirá y quedará algo así
y como pudiste ver antes tenía una
apertura arriba pero después de que se
llena se abre para el otro lado por lo
que las partículas que entraron se tiran
dentro de la célula y como lo mencioné
antes esto es un tipo de transporte
pasivo debido a que solo se trata del
movimiento de las partículas a favor de
su gradiente de concentración si aquí no
hubiera una membrana celular las
partículas se hubieran movido en esta en
esta dirección
tendríamos más partículas moviéndose en
esta dirección en un cierto tiempo que
bueno que las partículas moviéndose
hacia el sentido contrario al tener la
membrana celular estorbando esto no es
tan sencillo pero las proteínas
acarreador 'las facilitan el
porte pasivo facilitan la difusión